>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: A "NEW YORK TIMES"
STORY MAY HAVE BACK FIRED IN
SPECTACULAR FASHION.
WITH A NEW REPORT THAT MAY
INDICATE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DID , IN FACT SPY
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
BURIED DEEP IN YESTERDAY'S PIECE
ON THE RUSSIAN PROBE, 40
PARAGRAPHS DOWN WAS THIS
REVELATION:
REVELATION
PRESIDENT TRUMP REACTED BY
TWEETING THIS COULD BE BIGGER
THAN WATERGATE.
WAS THIS A MISSTEP OR DONE ON
PURPOSE?
ROGER STONE REJOINS US FOR
REACTION TO THIS MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT.
AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR MOLLY
HEMMING WAY AND FORMER
WHITEWATER PROSECUTOR SAL.
YOUR REACTION.
>> IT'S SHOCKING THAT THE FBI
PENETRATED AND HAD AN
UNDER-COVER PERSON ON THE
TRUMPICAL PAIN.
AND USED THE LESSER STANDARDS --
>> Laura: EXPLAIN THAT FOR US.
YOU DON'T NEED A CRIMINAL PRED
CAT?
>> YOU DON'T.
IT'S ONE THING TO SAY THEY HAD
ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO OPEN AN
INVESTIGATION OF WHETHER THERE
WAS RUSSIAN SPYING, BUT THEY
WERE NOT CLOSE TO BEING NEAR
ABLE TO SAY WE HAVE EVIDENCE OF
SPYING BY PEOPLE IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
THEY COULD NOT OPEN A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION SO THEY USED THE
EXCUSE OF COUNTER-INTELLIGENCE.
IT'S A HUGE SCANDAL.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IT WAS PUT IN THAT STORY BECAUSE
THEY KNEW IT WOULD COME OUT.
THEY COULD SAY THAT'S OLD NEWS
AND NOT A BIG DEAL.
>> IT'S NOT THAT THIS MIGHT BE
HAPPENING THAT THE FBI WAS
SPYING, BUT WE HAVE MULTILE
FORMER FBI OFFICIALS SAYS THERE
WAS BROAD SURVEILLANCE ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
IT WASN'T JUST CARTER PAGE.
IT WAS WIRETAPS AND NATIONAL
SECURITY LETTERS AND AT LEAST
ONE HUMAN INTELLIGENCE SOURCE.
WE DON'T KNOW A LOT.
HOW MANY THERE WERE.
WERE THEY SENT IN BY THE FBI?
IT'S NOT A QUESTION THAT THIS
MIGHT INDICATE THERE IS SPYING,
THEY SAID THEY SPIED IN A BROAD
FASHION.
>> Laura: REMEMBER WHEN TRUMP
WAS RIDICULED WHEN HE SAID I WAS
WIRETAPPED.
HE WAS RIGHT.
>> HE WAS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THIS HAS TO BE SEEN IN CONTENT.
NOT ONLY DID THEY USE A PHONEY,
FABRICATED DOSSIER AS THE
UNDER-LYING LEGAL RATIONALE FOR
THE SPYING ON THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE FOR PRESIDENT.
USING THE POWER AND THE
AUTHORITY AND THE CAPABILITY OF
THE STATE TO SPY ON A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE, BUT THEY
INFILLERATED THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WITH AN FBI AGENT.
THIS MAKES WATERGATE LOOK LIKE
SMALL POTATOES.
>> Laura: IT LOOKS LIKE THIS GUY
WHO TEACHES AT CAMBRIDGE AND AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN.
YOU KNOW HIM, ROGER?
>> I PLAYED POKER WITH HIM.
HE IS EXCELLENT.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN SOMEONE WHO
SUGGESTED A LOT OF THINGS TO THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
HE DIDN'T WORK FOR THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
IT WAS REPORTED THAT HE
APPROACHED MANY DIFFERENT TRUMP
CAMPAIGN PEOPLE TO GIVE THEM
INFORMATION.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> WELL, YOU WOULD CALL A
POTENTIAL ENTRAPMENT.
I HAD NOT HEARD THAT YET.
IT WOULD NOT SURPRISE ME.
IT'S SHOCKEY ENOUGH BASED ON THE
FLIMSY EVIDENCE THAT THEY HAD,
THEY WOULD PUT SOMEONE IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
THE FISA IS DISTURBING ENOUGH.
WE KNOW THEY DIDN'T REVEAL
SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT TO THE
FISA COURT.
TO HAVE A PLANT IN THE POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN OF YOUR OPPONENT.
IF YOU DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
YOU BETTER HAVE DYNAMITE AND
THEY DIDN'T HAVE DYNAMITE.
IT'S PART OF A PATTERN.
THE PATTERN OF SALLY YATES
INVESTIGATING MIKE FLYNN AND
PART OF A DISTURBING THING.
>> THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL
PROBLEM.
CONGRESS IS TRYING TO FIND OUT
INFORMATION ABOUT THESE THINGS.
THE FBI IS TELLING THEM THEY
CAN'T TURN OVER THAT
INFORMATION.
AT THE SAME TIME YOU ARE SEEING
LEAKS WITH PERSONAL INFORMATION
ABOUT THE SOURCE THAT WAS USED.
THEY ARE TELLING THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" AND THE "WASHINGTON
POST," BUT THEY WON'T TURN OVER
THE INFORMATION TO CONGRESS.
>> Laura: BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
MAKE THEMSELVES LOOK AS GOOD AS
POSSIBLE BEFORE OTHER DOCUMENTS
COME OUT.
THIS NARRATIVE IS TAINTED.
BURYING THE LEAD IN THE "NEW
YORK TIMES."
ROGER, RUDY SAID THEY ARE DID
YOU SAYING WITH MUELLER
NARROWING THE SCOPE OF THE
QUESTIONS.
I DON'T LIKE HIM TALKING TO BOB
MUELLER AT ALL.
I THINK THIS WHOLE THING STINKS
TO HIGH EVEN.
-- HEAVEN.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY MADE
PROGRESS.
>> THERE IS NO CIRCUMSTANCE
UNDER WHICH THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
GO IN FOR AN INTERVIEW.
IT'S A PERJURY TRAP.
THE IDEA THAT ROB ROSENSTEIN AND
JEFF SESSIONS WON'T TURN OVER TO
CONGRESS A CO-EQUAL BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT INFORMATION REGARDING
THE SURVEILLANCE OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> Laura: YOU THINK OBAMA HAD NO
KNOWLEDGE?
>> ON THE CONTRARY, WHAT DID THE
PRESIDENT KNOW?
>> Laura: HOW DID THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES NOT KNOW
ABOUT THIS?
>> PETER STRZOK'S TEXT MESSAGE
INDICATE.
>> Laura: I GO BACK TO RICE'S
MESSAGE.
SAL, NARROWING THE SCOPE OF THE
QUESTIONS.
IS THAT GIVING YOU ANY SENSE OF
COMFORT THEY WOULD GO IN THERE
AND ANSWER QUESTIONS BY MUELLER
GIVEN EVERYTHING WE KNOW NOW?
>> AS I SAID MANY TIMES ON THIS
SHOW, IF DONALD TRUMP WERE ANY
WHITE COLLAR CLIENT, FAMOUS OR
NOT IN THIS CIRCUMSTANCE, I
WOULD PHYSICALLY PREVENT HIM
FROM GOING IN FOR THAT
QUESTIONING.
ON THE POINT THAT ROGER RAISED
ABOUT THE INFORMATION THAT THE
DOJ DOESN'T WANT TO GIVE OVER.
THERE ARE GOOD RENS FOR NOT
GIVING OVER SOURCES OF AND
METHODS.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE DOJ AND THE
FBI, THEY WERE CAUGHT SAYING
SEVERAL TIMES, WE CAN'T TURN
THIS OVER BECAUSE IT'S
SENSITIVE.
WHEN THEY BACK DOWN AND UNREDACT
IT, IT'S EMBARRASSING.
THEY HAVE A CREDIBILITY PROBLEM.
>> Laura: THEY SAID PAPADOPOULOS
WAS THE IMPETUS FOR THE
INVESTIGATION.
HE SEEMS LIKE A GOOFBALL.
I DON'T KNOW HIM.
LIKE CARTER PAGE AND
PAPADOPOULOS.
THIS IS LIKE RIDICULOUS!
THEY ARE NOT CHARACTERS YOU
WOULD IMAGINE COMPILING
INFORMATION.
NEVERTHELESS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT
THEM.
WHO IS APPROACHING HIM AT THE
TIME.
>> RIGHT, AT FIRST WE WERE TOLD
THERE WERE QUESTIONS ABOUT
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE WITH THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE MORE WE LEARN ABOUT WHAT LED
THEM TO THINK THAT, IT BOGGLES
THE MIND THAT PROFESSIONALS
WOULD HAVE STARTED ANY
INVESTIGATION AT ALL OVER THESE
VERY PIDDLING THINGS.
THEY WERE SPYING ON AT LEAST 4
TRUMP CAMPAIGN OFFICIALS AND
USING POWERS OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE TO DO THIS.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP, IT'S A
HORRIBLE PRECEDENT TO SPY ON
PRESIDENTIAL OPPONENTS.
>> Laura: THEY SPIED ON YOU?
>> THE "NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED
THERE WAS A FISA WARRANT ON ME.
I TALKED TO THOSE REPORTERS.
THEY WON'T RETRACT THEIR STORY.
I ASKED FOR INFORMATION.
IT WAS DENIED.
>> Laura: I AM NOT SAYING THIS
AS A REPUBLICAN OR CONSERVATIVE,
I FIND IT FRIGHTENING THAT THE 4
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COULD
BE USEED IN IN MANNER IN THE